when I go to your website for your film
then there was Joe I noticed you have a
ton of press from your hometown or from
surrounding areas and they seem so
welcoming of you how is that then to
know that yes when you come to your new
home in LA it's a different ballgame and
that it's not personal but it's just
there's so many people doing the same
thing so to be so embraced yeah and and
and cheered on and then coming back here
knowing that you have to be your own
cheerleader really absolutely yeah so
what's what's interesting about and like
this was like was kind of my strategy
actually for making my first film I
wanted to do it in a place where be like
supported and because the the crazy part
is that kind of anywhere outside of LA
outside of California if you make a
movie like that's newsworthy you know
because it's just not a normal thing
that a lot of people do but out here in
LA everybody's making a movie like it's
and and you know I I hate to you like
use the term everybody but a whole lot
of people are making stuff out here to
the point where it's it's relatively
normalized and like for instance I I'm
whenever I go to a coffee shop to just
get a cup of coffee if you just look at
people's laptops
9 out of 10 screen someone's writing a
screenplay and that is like not normal
anywhere else
kind of outside of LA and so it was
amazing we premiered my film then there
was Joe with the Arkansas cinema Society
which is like put on by Jeff Nichols who
directed mud and Midnight Special and
stuff like that so it was great because
like they they saw my film and and
believed in it and so they were like
we're gonna put on a basically a
premiere for it and there was just a
level of excitement that I just haven't
experienced kind of anywhere else
because it was it was a bit of like a
hometown hero kind of
to it but also like people just truly
went to the movies to enjoy themselves I
think sometimes out here in LA we can go
to the movies to judge like that's where
we go I have like we walk in with like
this better impressed me but back home
in Arkansas people like there's like it
was almost like a magic like you walk
into this dark room with all these
strangers and it's like okay what's
gonna happen and and being in that
posture about to watch a film it's like
a totally different vibe and I think
that actually most of the world
experiences movies that way of uh I want
to go and I want to be entertained and I
want to be moved and I want to have fun
and sometimes living out here in LA can
be easy to lose track of that because
sometimes we can try to just impress our
filmmaker friends but like did you see
that dope shot and that thing that was
tight right and but like I knew that
that the film I was making in particular
uh is for like an audience to consume
and it's for people who live live lives
outside of the entertainment industry
it's about regular people going through
what they're doing and and there's
redemption at the end and I know you
know sometimes like when I'm shooting my
scripts to friends or they shoot me
their scripts like you know there's a
thing it was like George Lucas or
somebody it said like there's only like
seven plots there's only seven plots in
the world or something like that and
like there's some truth to that I think
like but the just just like how you can
kind of only make a car or kind of like
one way really you know it's like it
usually has four wheels it sometimes
doesn't have to have four wheels you can
make a cart with three wheels I'm sure
but like the reality is that like I
think the majority of people usually
will give a movie a chance in ways that
sometimes like after you've gone through
film school you've already decided like
uh I already I've already seen this
before because I know where this is
going and you're way ahead of the mood
and something you know you can get into
that habit and kind of stop enjoying
films and so what what making my my
feature kind of taught me is it helped
me remember what movies are for and what
they do and what they mean to me and
seeing that in Arkansas was just a
beautiful beautiful experience and it
rejuvenated me and it made me want to
keep going because I got really scared
after I finished my film because I was
so tired I was so exhausted that I was I
had a moment where I was like I don't
think I want to do this anymore like I
think I think I might be one and done
and something happened when the lights
went down and everybody got quiet and my
my movie is a comedy drama into dramedy
if you will but the the first couple
tile cards is a joke and it takes you a
second to get it because it's it it
starts and then there's another title
card and then another and then another
and everybody immediately busted out
laughing and I was like ah they're in
they get it they get it and I showed
that to a lot of my friends out here and
they were like this is dumb oh really
down oh my god but I knew it was funny
you know and and so I've that's the
other thing it's taught me this whole
process is just like trusting your voice
and knowing that your voice and your
opinion of things how you feel about
something is totally valid and even if
it's standing outside of a group of
people and a group of people don't agree
if you feel strongly about something
there's probably at least a million
other people in the world that feel the
same way and this process the notes
process and we were talking about
earlier also like just helped me know
when to trust my voice I think you you
said your family has this unofficial
rule I saw this in one of the interviews
that you did I'm taking this from the
paper but if you're afraid of something
that that will make you a stronger
better person that's probably the thing
you need to do right yeah yeah yeah
because like I I think fear is a really
good indicator
it's an indicator of perhaps like your
your destiny in a weird way I don't want
to get too new agey in here but let me
turn off the inside but to me in my
brain I feel like like there's a better
side of you on the other side of fear
because like things I'm not afraid of
are things usually don't they don't mean
that much to me you know I'm usually
afraid of the things that mean the most
to me you know I'm I'm like right before
we we launched my the Kickstarter for my
film like I had never experienced that
much fear in my whole life cuz I was
like oh my gosh this is public if I fail
it's gonna be public everyone's gonna
know about it and like I hesitated for a
while and so there was like a week where
I didn't post it and I was like I don't
know if I can do this right now
and like I thankfully like my my I have
a really supportive family and really
supportive wife and and there was like
you have to do this like you have to
it's your destiny if you will and and I
and I've noticed that every single time
where I've been utterly terrified and
I've pushed through it I've I've only
succeeded and I don't mean that in like
an arrogant way I mean that in the sense
of like I jumped off the cliff and
suddenly a trampoline appeared right
before I smacked the ground and that has
happened so many times and and I think
for anyone who's put together a feature
film like like you guys you you
understand that you know that like those
things happen you kind of move before
any of the pieces are in place and
suddenly magically the pieces are in
place and I've I now love that feeling
I love sort of jumping off to see like
okay am I gonna is something gonna catch
me and nine times out of ten it does and
when it doesn't I'll I'll figure it out
and it's just been a that's been a
recurring theme throughout my whole life
it's just if you're afraid of it you
have to do it
you